[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le débat ce soir
nous parlerons de laïcité nous avons
choisi ce thème suite à une polémique
qui revenait régulièrement à cette même
époque de l'année les crèches de noël
ont-elles leur place dans les bâtiments
républicains face aux décisions
contradictoires rendues par plusieurs
tribunaux administratifs le conseil
d'état a été saisi et a dû trancher il
autorise l'installation des crèches à
certaines conditions est ce un tournant
dans l'interprétation de notre laïcité à
la française avec nous pour en débattre
ce soir juliette snit heures vous êtes
conseiller municipal europe ecologie les
verts à guyancourt également conseillère
fédérale du parti olivier de la faire
vous êtes conseiller départemental les
républicains des yvelines et conseiller
municipal de versailles bonsoir à tous
les deux juliette sanitaire je me tourne
d'abord vers vous une crèche de noël
dans une mairie ça vous dérange écoutez
déjà je vous remercie d'avoir organisé
ce débat sur des sujets qui sont
particulièrement intéressants
première question qu'on peut se poser
c'est qu'est ce que la laïcité
républicaine alors la laïcité
républicaine à la française c'est la
laïcité la liberté individuelle c'est la
laïcité du givre ensemble et si une
laïcité qui se veut d'apaisement c'est
la liberté pour chacune et chacun de
croire ou de ne pas croire ont une
religion et d'exercer librement son
culte et une crèche de noël alors dans
un bâtiment républicain va à l'encontre
de ses objectifs effectivement ce que
rappelle le conseil d'état dans son avis
c'est que l'installation d'une crèche de
noël à caractère religieux
dans un bâtiment public est interdite
alors là où ils sèment un petit peu la
confusion c'est qui continue en disant
que éventuellement ou pour en installer
à condition qu'elles soient culturelles
ou artistiques ou festives malanda leur
gestuelle
s'il de dissocier les décorations de
noël le sapin de noël la crèche c'est ça
fait partie d'une tradition mais oui
mais dans ce cas on peut se demander
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une crèche de
noël festi ou artistiques sont crèche de
noël dans lequel il ya aucun symbole
religieux sans le petit jésus sans mari
donc avec des villageois un âne un boeuf
je ne sais pas des santons mais son sens
en symboles religieux la question que je
me pose olivier de la faire vous cette
interprétation un peu libérale de la
laïcité qu'en pensez vous mais moins
très sincèrement j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui la liberté de pouvoir
maintenir nos traditions aussi dans dans
l'ensemble des et des établissements
français et public me choque pas au sens
où la laïcité c'est pas l'abstraction de
toutes les religions on peut se rappeler
quand même que la france a une une
culture à une
à ses racines chrétiennes et donc
pourquoi oublier notre passé au enfin
pour vous envie de dire retirer de tous
les établissements publics notre passé
notre notre histoire j'invitais c'est un
peu dommage donc aujourd'hui après on
peut laisser la liberté à chacun de le
faire ou de ne pas le faire on peut on
peut permettre gervais dire à toutes les
communes de de choisir en l'occurrence
j'ai envie de dire on n'est pas obligé
non plus de tout ce devoir supprimer
aujourd'hui sous prétexte de la laïcité
qui n'est pas qui n'est pour moi pas
l'abstraction des religions et encore
moins la religion chrétienne ce qu'elle
soulève certain c'est que on doit avoir
un sentiment de neutralité en entrant
dans le hall de ses bâtiments oui mais
pourquoi pourquoi on doit avoir la
neutralité aujourd'hui en france
pourquoi on en arrive à une laïcité
aussi aussi aussi importante aujourd'hui
en france
revenons un peu en arrière je pense
aujourd'hui aussi on a peut-être vu
aussi monter des religions à côté qui
ont pris beaucoup de place et
effectivement pas ça peut choquer
charest certains et on voudrait
aujourd'hui interdire ça et au détriment
des religions qui jusqu'à présent
faisait pas de bruit continuer d'avancer
je ne stigmatise pas mais messi vit
effectivement on a vu le radicalisme
islamique monter depuis les années et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui sous prétexte de
voir aussi ce radicalisme montée on veut
interdire aux autres religions d'exister
moi je suis très choquée effectivement
quand on dit aujourd'hui à ma fille de
pas mettre de médailles à l'école mais à
côté de ça de voir une maman avec un
foulard islamique rentrée dans l'école
donc là il ya eu des lois sur justement
le voile et cette loi de 2011 qui
interdit effectivement de le dissimuler
le visage donc ça existe finalement il
était peut-être un peu juste aussi que
ça fasse écho
sur d'autres d'autres religions oui mais
jusqu'à présent j'ai envie de dire
toutes les religions elles se sont
organisées elles se sont
elles ont d'abord toujours existé en
france on est ici d'une religion
chrétienne
effectivement on n'a pas non plus
fâcheux dira tout voir tout de se cacher
de tous pourquoi supprimer nos crèches
alors que quand vous voyez tous ces
enfants qui débarque dans les mairies
regarder les crèches c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez fantastique
pourquoi j'en veux dire devoir supprimer
nos fêtes de noël dans ces cas-là ça non
mais ah ben voilà mais oui oui nommé la
fête de noël c'est avant tout une fête
religieuse dans ces cas là on pourrait
aussi aller plus loin et il retirer
aussi s'est fait donner un peu difficile
du lecteur c'est de différencier le
culturel du cultuel et de pas ôté
l'aspect festif et féerique de ces
moments mais vous savez la laïcité c'est
pas une opinion ou une croyance la
laïcité c'est un principe d'organisation
notre société c'est à dire que l'église
est séparée de l'état par la loi de 1905
donc cette loi de 1905 elle fait en
sorte que toutes les religions soient
mises à égale distance il n'y a pas une
religion qui prime sur l'autre même même
si la tradition chrétienne est plus
ancienne que d'autres et encore je ne
sais pas nos ancêtres les gaulois
n'était pas n'était pas catholique ou
chrétiens mais l'ancien en france en
tout cas la france est quand même un
pays multiculturel qui s'est construit
au fur et à mesure de vagues
d'immigration d'un peu de part et
d'autre et la chrétienté là depuis
longtemps mais il n'y a pas qu'elle est
reconnaître qu'une
tradition confessionnelles donc c'est
elle que les trucages de noël
puisse être puisse venir dans les
mairies puis de venir dans nos espaces
qui sont censés être neutres des espaces
où tout le monde a le droit d'être bien
tout le monde que ce soit des musulmans
des juifs des athées et des agnostiques
n'importe qui doit se sentir à l'aise
donc il y intègre attend vous
introduisez une notion de confort
finalement
psychologique pour des gens qui auraient
des confessions différentes oui mais
c'est le principe d'un autre république
à la laïcité à la française c'est à dire
veut dire tout simplement qu'il n'ya
aucun souci pour pratiquer une religion
on va pas quand j'ai entendu à droite et
à gauche raser les églises ou des
mosquées c'est pas du tout ça la
question quelqu'un qui va avoir une
crèche de noël il installe chez lui je
pense faire une crèche magnifique ou
alors dans une église financée par les
fonds de l'église puisque ça le lait les
installations religieuse ne doit pas
être toute religion ne doit pas être
financé par l'état et donc voilà il ya
aucun problème je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous pour dire que la
religion doit être séparée des de tous
les problèmes politiques fassent de
toute la vie politique française on est
on là dessus on est complètement
d'accord en revanche pourquoi on devrait
sacrifier entre guillemets toute notre
histoire de notre patrimoine notre
culture parce que aujourd'hui sous
prétexte de la laïcité on doit on ne
devrait plus voir de crèche alors que
vous allez en provence vous avez des
crèches par tout ça cc c'est à dire
c'est une piste et culturel en provence
la cresse dans dans dans toutes les
maisons dans toutes les mairies dans
toutes les dans toutes les communes où
vous voyez une crèche parce que vous
avez des santons de provence aix en
provence qu'on veut qu'on vend partout
qui et qui aussi j'ai envie de dire ces
agressions de magique les lectrices de
provence le l'histoire de l'histoire
qu'était et qui était raconté aussi avec
avec tout tout tout ses paroliers de de
provence et pourquoi on devrait
sacrifier notre culture au pour la
laïcité voilà moi ça me choque un petit
peu parce que j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui on a une histoire on doit
pas avoir honte de notre histoire on
regarde aujourd'hui vous vous regardez
notre est versailles regarder à
versailles le monde entier vient il est
le monde de faim vient voir visiter le
château de versailles et c'est notre
histoire c'est
alors si c'est pas une emblème religieux
mais à côté de ça à côté de ça ça c'est
à dire c'est notre culture il y aura pas
sacrifier notre culture tout ce qui est
beau tout ce qui attire les gens moi
mettez vous dans une crèche et regarder
les gens passer devant une crèche vous
allez voir tous ces enfants fait la joie
des enfants c'est quelque chose de
fantastique aussi pourquoi on notait la
question est ce que justement
cette laïcité un peu de surveillance
comme certains l'appellent est-ce que
c'est pas aussi le moyen de garantir la
laïcité c'est à dire de garantir que
sous tous ses aspects les principes
fondamentaux sont respectés je crois que
si on veut garantir la laïcité c'est
faire en sorte qu'on puisse que chacun
puisse entre guillemets
avoir son culte comme ils le souhaitent
et
et pouvoir faire c'est fait les fêtes
religieuses ofa religieuse musulmane
juive et chrétienne je crois que ça
c'est quelque chose mais pour mais
pourquoi pas mais pourquoi pas j'ai
envie dès aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
regarder toutes les fêtes toutes les
fêtes qui sont faites dans les villages
les fêtes de dés des vignerons c'est
toujours avec un saint les fêtes de 2,2
de femmes aiment regarder même toutes
les grandes fêtes que ce soit pas que la
toussaint ce sont toujours des grands
moments en plus qui sont des moments
festifs pour la plupart du temps des
moments où on se retrouve en famille et
pourquoi j'invite à pourquoi on devrait
supprimer toute cette vision
toute cette belle fatou de tous leurs
rêves s'il n'y a pas du tout supprimer
c'est pas du tout cela ici parce que je
veux dire vous avez ça dans la rue quand
vous avez ça dans une mairie quand vous
êtes dans l'établissement va dans une
ville je trouve que l'accession
mais en fait les ça c'est que
la mairie jean veut dire après on en
supprime le sapin on supprime la
décoration de noël n'est pas rien repris
par les catholiques mais le sapin mais
janvier festive et c'est ce qui vous
arrivera en matière d'égalité des
religions il ya deux chemins possibles
soit on veille à ne privilégier aucune
religion soit toutes les favoriser c'est
à dire quand les favoris tout ça on a
déjà brisé il s'agite pas oublier notre
histoire en larmes il y en a pas une qui
priment sur les autres alors à partir du
mot maintenant à partir de mon install
d'une crèche dans une mairie donc dans
un lieu public un lieu qui est censé
être neutre sanctuary zay
on aura envie les autres religions la
barre ont envie de 10 d'y installer
aussi quelque chose au moment de leur
fait
quand on met une crèche dans une mairie
c'est aussi quelque chose de
traditionnel
c'est la tradition j'ai envie de dire ça
se perpétue
nono fête de village à se perpétue nos
enfin toutes nos fêtes religieuses de
tout au long de l'année c'est des choses
pour perpétue toute l'année dans cette
année c'est la ccc les françaises vous
avez un calendrier avec les fêtes
française avait dès les vacances de noël
les vacances de pâques
bah oui c'est le csss et justement c'est
justement c'est justement bien dommage
d'oublier ça parce que on oublie aussi
que derrière janvier bien y'a
bon il ya tout le côté festif et le côté
rassemblement famille il ya tout ce lien
social concret rester avec cette fête
qui est concret avec ses fêtes abbaoui
mais servir quand vous faites des fêtes
de villages qui sont souvent religieuse
parce que vous avez souvent
ça commence par une messe que ce soit
afin d'en dans le dos dans les communes
souvent la forêt interdite devrait
interdire tout ça j'ai envie de retour
pour la france la france est un pays les
plus athées au monde et 60% des français
ne reconnaissent pas de religion ou se
reconnaissent que mater ils sont 42 ans
en restant il y a les catholiques les
juifs les musulmans il ya toutes les
autres confessions 100% défense haute et
on doit être
à nous
pour ouvrir un tout petit peu le débat
on sent quand même que si le conseil
d'état a dû trancher il ya une espèce de
crispation quand même autour de cette
thématique là des tribunaux
administratifs n'était pas d'accord dans
un quartier une association laïque qui a
donc voulu avoir un recours judiciaire
dans l'autre c'est le préfet qu'est ce
que ça veut dire de l'état d'esprit
contemporain selon vous juliette 16h
que malheureusement la laïcité et
grignoter de plus en plus elle est
attaquée on l'a vu d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui avec monseigneur pompiers
qui a écrit au président de la
république
pour pour insister sur un texte
législatif pour demander au président
que telle ne soit pas n'aboutissent pas
c'est
inadmissible c'est vraiment un on
attaque la laïcité mais de plein fouet
donc il faut pas il faut pas laisser
faire ça une religion n'a pas à se mêler
du législatif d'un pays et pour revenir
pour en revenir aux crèches de noël le
conseil d'état est très claire il dit il
me peuples d'ailleurs je les laisse ou
la wii alors vers le midwest maintenant
on va se passer de la lecture
le conseil d'état dit qu'on ne peut pas
installer une crèche de noël à caractère
religieux dans un bâtiment public donc
mairie conseil régional conseil
départemental
donc dans ce cas là moi j'aimerais bien
que ce soit ici on me suis arrêté sur la
culture elle est un oeil aux traditions
mais dans ce cas là on retire le petit
on met un père noël à la place de jésus
on met des petits enfants qui jouent
mais on retire toute connotation
religieuse et là ça deviendra quelque
chose de traditionnel pour tous les
français quelle que soit leur confession
merci gelsinger olivier d'affaires et
les y conclut et pourquoi devra revendre
devrions-nous avoir honte de notre
religion de notre de notre passé qui est
à caractère que chrétien où l'on fasse
de dire ça fait partie de notre histoire
on doit pas avoir honte on a eu des
crèches depuis des milliers d'années en
france
pourquoi on devrait faire abstraction de
notre passé moi j'ai pas honte de mon
passé j'ai pas honte de mes parents j'ai
pas honte de mes aînés et les parents de
mon passé et je trouve que c'est dommage
aujourd'hui d'entendre jeudi d'aider des
politiques qui veulent justement faire
abstraction de tout ça j'en veux dire
c'est là notre fierté aujourd'hui devant
le monde entier c'est notre fierté c'est
le malheureux la religion et tout ce qui
a été fait par la religion catholique
jusqu'à présent c'est notre fierté et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup à
apprendre aux fruits de ce qui c'est
c'est aussi par les cathos et je pense
qu'on n'a pas à rougir de ce qui a été
fait aujourd'hui parler par les
chrétiens vous pouvez regarder
aujourd'hui tous les hospices tout ce
qui était fait par les chrétiens
mais on n'a pas à avoir honte force que
je veux juste dire c'est qu'on n'a pas à
avoir honte de ce qu'ils étaient
tiens et donc on doit pouvoir
aujourd'hui j'en veux dire c'est enfin
par les fermiers parler de ce que de ce
que est ce qui a été construit ce
qu'elle construit la france ce qu'elle
construit notre pays et l'histoire de
nos pays merci à tous les deux d'être
venu sur ce plateau c'est la fin de
cette émission 7 8 le débat on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau débat merci à vous merci
[Musique]